all right all right so what do you want
to do today what do you want to
accomplish today
that's a great question it's a great
question i think well you are you're a
clinical psychologist so i do want to i
think for my own life it's important
that i
selfishly use this a little bit to get
advice from you personally
um uh which i think is which could can
help other people as well
uh yes i i have the new book here which
is called
uh beyond order which i love the title
of that 12 more rules for life which was
written
i know a good chunk of this was written
before your ordeal
um which we could talk about too um
and you know just the it's so funny on
the on the book it says the new york
times has called you the most
influential public intellectual in the
western world which is undoubtedly true
it's a tremendous amount of pressure and
do you ever say to yourself
like do you ever look at the western
world and go you know what i don't want
to be
the most influential public intellectual
i don't want to be responsible in any
way for what's going on
uh um i i would say i vary in that
opinion
moment to moment every day um you know
i'm in an extraordinary
extremely fortunate position but it's
also
a strange position and it isn't exactly
clear to me how to conceptualize it or
how to move forward in the position that
i'm in so i'm
actively working that through
do you like fame like do you like the
adulation of people because you've
helped a tremendous amount of people
um and you're very well known that also
comes with
uh obviously a lot of negatives um
but there's a ton of positives to it and
do you
have you grown to to like them to like
the idea of being famous
well i find it very difficult to
accustom myself to
it happened to me quite late in life and
so
it's still very strange for me to
walk down the street and be recognized
continually it in some of it's extremely
positive it's it's as if i'm
always among friends and well-wishers i
mean you wouldn't get that impression if
you
looked at my reputation online let's say
because there's a disproportionate
number of journalists who
have taken a dislike to me but when i'm
out in public
it's like being it's like living in a
small town but
everywhere in some sense because but in
a small town
like that was this subject of a 1950s
you know romantic romanticized version
of a small town where everyone
loves each other and um people are
always telling me that they're happy to
see me walking around and looking
healthy and
or or they just say hello or they you
know do a thumbs up or yell something
out and
so it's like being among friends and
well-wishers except it's more intimate
than that
and it's extraordinarily positive but
also very difficult to conceptualize
i was walking with a friend of mine this
morning who's a clinical psychologist
and
i was talking about this issue and
about the impact that my communication
has had culturally and
and um at the level of individual lives
and
you know i i mentioned to her and we
discussed
the fact that
so much of this isn't the consequence of
my ideas
you know i've read widely and
i i read people who's who were very
profound thinkers
nietzsche and dostoevsky and young
people who know me know that they were
great influences on me but much more
widely than not many
neuroscientists and many literary
figures and
and of course people like jung and
nietzsche and dostoevsky were
overwhelmingly influenced by their own
reading and their own knowledge their
knowledge of christianity the knowledge
of our religious traditions
in jung's case his psychoanalytic
practice and his work with
schizophrenics and
i've read much of the major works by all
the major clinical psychologists and
i've been able to communicate those
ideas to synthesize them to some degree
and then to communicate them to very
large numbers of people it's not that
surprising the ideas have
a profound effect because they were
written by geniuses who were
interested in helping people sort out
their lives and
and live more meaningful lives and so
um on the one hand it's not surprising
that the ideas have
that influence but on the other it's
difficult
it's complex to be the person who's
identified with that right to such a
great degree you're the conduit
yes which is a cliched thing in some
sense you know
artists say that that they're just a
conduit but there's truth in that
and people say that i articulate what
they already know
and that that's helpful and i believe
that to be the case because otherwise it
wouldn't
echo and reverberate right um and as
powerfully as it does one of your rules
which i
i looked at here in the new book it said
um
and i want to ask you about this it says
do not allow yourself to become
resentful um deceitful or arrogant
the first part of that you i've
witnessed um
and i know that you've lived and i i've
never seen an attack on someone like
i've seen on you and i've been
i paid attention you know i'm a comedian
i'm i i talk about
cultural issues i i um
you know am relatively well versed in
what's going on in the public sphere
i've never seen uh attempt after attempt
after attempt to smear uh and like
besmirch
a human being as i saw with you i've ne
i mean there was um much less
and i'm i'm serious about this there was
maybe less
negative press about osama bin laden
than
you i mean i mean i like i i think there
was
more of like people trying to understand
osama bin laden
um you know he grew up uh you know when
he was disenfranchised or whatever it
was
but how do you not especially because
you went through this very powerful
ordeal
and i don't know how and i know that a
lot of that was internal family dynamics
and your own health and your family's
health
but how do you not become resentful
against
uh the people that have uh
tried to assassinate your character also
do you blame any of them for what you
went through
recently which we'll we'll talk about in
a little bit but you know the ordeal
that you went through do you blame any
of these people
do you do you say to yourself had they
not been as aggressive
and had they not been as vicious uh you
might not have been in the situation you
were in
well you know i worked through a lot of
the answers to the questions that you're
asking while i was writing
this second book the last chapter the
chapter you referred to do not do not
become
resentful deceitful or arrogant those
are the three things that i noticed
that were particularly catastrophic
to people in my clinical practice those
three things and their interactions
and then in the in the final chapter
chapter 12 is
be grateful in spite of your suffering
um
look the first thing i'd say is that
i've watched people since i've
become public a public figure
i've watched people my my peers let's
say academics in other places
in the world or people who are roughly
my professional peers who've been the
target of attacks
on twitter or in the newspapers
in some manner similar to what's
happened to me
and my observation has been that it's
very very hard on people they generally
fold up and apologize and are shocked
and hurt
quite to a quite deep degree and so
it's no joke to
to have that happen to you it's it's
given me more insight into why people
are so likely to not say the things they
need to say
when it's the time to say them because
the trouble that that can cause
is very difficult to cope with
and so i certainly wouldn't say that
it's been without effect
it's also a great mystery to me that it
continually happens
i continually expect it to stop but
it doesn't stop and i don't it's hard to
understand why
that is exactly um i'm i'm trying to
understand that all the time
uh i think to some degree
there's a public attempt to understand
that even
and i say that because i'm also the
subject of
an inordinate number of memes and
they represent who people think i am
um in a very large number of ways
strange ways i've become very associated
with lobster imagery and with frog
imagery and with
king imagery and with well the red skull
imagery and
it's a very complex set of of images and
so
that all adds to the difficulty of
sorting it out as as far as i'm
concerned
i certainly was tempted towards
bitterness
and resentment as a consequence of my
illness which created a tremendous
amount of pain
and well at the same time or
approximately the same time my daughter
and my wife were also very ill
and so it's difficult not to
succumb to the temptation to shake your
fist at god and
curse the clouds and the thunder and
this structure of being itself for
all the all the suffering that people
go through but it's not helpful
and i've really strived with the help
primarily of my wife but also of other
people close to me
to identify resentful and bitter
thoughts and to eradicate them
because they're not helpful they're not
justifiable like under any condition as
far as i can tell
to and that's why i tried to
illustrate in chapter 12 that gratitude
is most properly conceptualized
if it's not naive as a form of courage
it's sort of like the decision you take
when you decide to get married
you know the trope is that you find the
right person and then
you just know but the truth of the
matter is is that you
you decide and then you continually keep
deciding day after day while you're
living with the person and
gratitude in the face of life suffering
is the same thing it's
a decision about an attitude that you
are going to strive to bring forward it
isn't so much uh
it isn't so much a uh considered opinion
about the benevolence or lack thereof of
the world
right so and i just couldn't see when i
delved into my thoughts i thought this
seems unfair i
my family is struggling under a
tremendous burden
of ill health uh not that that's not
true of many many families i'm
very aware of that and and at the same
time this
in some sense rather unique uh
exposure to continual public pillaring
pillorying if that's a word probably
isn't
but but i d when i delved into it
identified all the thoughts and thought
them through
i couldn't see any positive utility they
weren't helping me in any way
so and i've done a reasonable job of
dispensing with them in the last two
months i would say at the same time
however i've also been recovering
to a fair degree since i've been
properly diagnosed finally
now what was that proper diagnosis for
the people that aren't aware of what you
went through because i know that there's
there was a lot of speculation because
there was really no information out
there when you kind of disappeared from
public life yeah
it's still not exactly clear what
happened to me i've had a long history
of depression and that
definitely has played a role in
predisposing me to
whatever happened over the last few
years but
my new physician
i i i was particularly suffering in the
mornings that
and by the end of the day i was back to
something approximating normal but it
would take me like eight hours or so of
real effort to
even get to the point where i could
stand up and move forward
to without excruciating pain without
believing that i was going to collapse
and then
that would recur every morning well he
investigated the structure of my sleep
and
found that i was i had severe central
sleep apnea and
i was waking up 25 times an hour so
those are stressful occurrences where
you stop
breathing and so i've been using a
breathing machine for the last
month and it's improved me from about
five percent of function to about 50 or
and and i'm still seem to be improving
at least to some degree
and so apparently i wasn't getting
i was wearing this ring that monitors
sleep and i was getting zero deep sleep
maybe one minute or two minutes a night
which is nowhere near enough
and since i've been using the machine
it's up to more like 30 to 50 minutes
that's where your body restores itself
completely it's during deep sleep
and so at least one of the problems that
i was facing it's not the only one but
at least one of them was
chronic lack of sleep and i know you had
anxiety and then you were having doubts
of anxiety
your wife's illness and michaela's
surgery and you're having
bouts of anxiety and then you're taking
uh you know a doctor prescribed
benzodiazepines to try to deal with that
and you keep upping the dosage of that
and um
then you you're having a uh
an atypical reaction to the medication
where you're having
yeah well both to the medication yeah
well
i started taking it in 2017.
i had an a pronounced episode of
insomnia
and it lasted for a long time about
three weeks i had very little sleep
um you know people have i said i think
on joe rogan that i didn't sleep for 21
days and
the cynics have pointed out that the
world record for sleeplessness is 11
days
but there's a big difference between
trying to stay awake which is what
you're doing
when you're trying to break a record and
being unable to sleep
those aren't the same thing at all and
perhaps i was micro sleeping when i was
laying down but my subjective experience
was three weeks without any sleep at all
i went to talk to and i had all sorts of
other symptoms that were quite
mysterious i
would faint when i stood up and
chronically and
i was ice cold i couldn't get warm no
matter how many blankets i piled on
um was this among other symptoms this
had to do with
stress well stress certainly but like
you start these
medications in 2017 had these things
happened prior to you taking
these medications well it's complicated
because i had a fat
a history of depression as well and i
stopped taking antidepressants in early
2016 and
that seemed to be going quite well but
it
either and i have an autoimmune disorder
so and what is it it's complicated like
an autoimmune disorder is just
i know that you know examples of that
are like lupus or something like that
yeah is it a um it's a what type of
disorder
is it i know that you're dying i haven't
had i haven't had arthritic symptoms but
i had psoriasis
quite in quite marked and um
uh a chronic history of mouth ulcers and
peripheral uveitis in my right eye which
is an inflammatory condition in the
retina
and i had um
i can't remember the name of it it's
it's your your hair follicles are
attacked by your immune system and
sometimes people go completely bald they
lose all their hair
i don't remember the alopecia alopecia
as well and is this why you have the
diet that you have because i remember
you said that the diet you have has
alleviated some of those symptoms yeah
well both my
wife and i have autoimmune problems and
so does my daughter although my son
doesn't
and my daughter's very severe arthritis
was
ameliorated to a tremendous degree by a
meat-only diet which she's maintained
for five years
and so both my wife and i while we're
still on that diet both of us
are still on that diet which i wouldn't
casually recommend to anyone by the way
it's very restrictive it's very hard on
my social life it makes it very
difficult to travel or to go out
but it does seem to keep these symptoms
essentially under control were you
diagnosed when when you and your wife
you both have this disorder do you have
similar disorders or
is her disorder hers is more severe okay
and and
you were diagnosed with that when you
were younger or was that did that come
on later in life
um well it it was diagnosed
mostly this year okay i mean these other
might these other
sort of symptomatic conditions sure
uveitis
and so on they were diagnosed as they
arose but this year
i was subject to a lot of medical tests
and i had
markers various blood markers of
autoimmune trouble
now do you did you would at any time did
you become addicted to the
benzodiazepines
well there's a not in that i was craving
them and
and not in that i was seeking them out
or or searching for them
um yes in that i was dependent on them
okay
so if i stopped taking them i would
undergo withdrawal and
that really when i stopped taking them
which i did in 2019
um once i realized their danger to me
some people don't seem to respond
negatively to them but i i certainly did
i stopped taking them and that that was
catastrophic do you have any other great
catastrophe for insights about addiction
having gone through this experience
well i wouldn't recommend it
i mean yeah
look lots of psychiatric drugs are
helpful to people
and but everything that's helpful comes
with a risk and
i mean antidepressants helped me a lot
and the benzodiazepine when i first took
it stopped my insomnia instantly
which is partly why i kept taking it
there were a lot of
stressful things going on in my life at
that time and i felt
especially because i had stopped taking
the antidepressants that
once i took the benzodiazepine and i'd
settled back down a bit that i would
just leave well enough alone and
i just so i kept taking it was
prescribed to me
i didn't know at that point that a small
proportion of people
we don't know how small have a
catastrophic dependency response so
they can't stop they can't get off the
medications without
suffering catastrophic side effects and
i was in that category so
yeah and then you were you went to i
believe moscow
and you were put in a medically induced
coma to
help you detox from the
medication well there was a variety of
reasons but that was definitely
that was the primary reason yes to get
through the worst of the withdrawal and
so
and after that happened i i haven't
taken any
uh benzodiazepines since then and you
when you woke up i was still suffering
terribly from the withdrawal effects
still eventually even after the detox
yes essentially yes so i mean these are
now benzodiazepines these are drugs that
are like would xanax
be considered yes okay so in that family
of drugs
yes alcohol barbiturates and
benzodiazepines are all
uh anti-anxiety agents alcohol is more
complex but
they're all in the same family and i
know that people have to medically detox
from alcohol
as well at a certain alcohol withdrawal
often kills people
yeah often yeah and they use xanax they
use benzodiazepines to treat the
to reduce the risk of seizure when
people withdraw from alcohol
right yeah and now waking up in moscow
which is like the chilling you know
why and i've heard a little bit about
this but you said you felt that you were
just your family made the decision to
move you
to moscow because they felt the
treatment there would be
better than canada or the u.s
well the treatments that i had in canada
in the u.s weren't working right
okay so it was a last-ditch attempt it
was a high-risk last-ditch attempt
yeah nobody did it lightly or or
carelessly it was just we we felt we
were out of options and i believe that
to be the case
right and and what was the treatment in
moscow other than the medically induced
coma what else
would you say like how it was was the
experience
i mean obviously it wasn't a positive
one but in terms of the doctors and the
hospital and the in the place that you
were in you felt that you were well
taken care of
they did their best yeah and all the
people medical professionals that i
dealt with generally speaking did their
best and
it's hard to tell what the effect of
that was
net positive or net negative i'm still
alive right you know
positive you roll the dice and take your
chances and and there's nothing certain
you know when my wife was treated for
her cancer
which was fatal a fatal form of cancer
and virtually a hundred percent of the
conditions of the cases uh noted it's
very rare
thankfully um she had quite
a radical second surgery and then
suffered terrible complications from
that surgery for six months their
life-threatening complications
but it saved her life yeah so you know
the cure can be the cure has danger just
like the disease
and your diet is very important because
i remember that you were saying on joe
rogan that you had had like an apple
juice and had such an adverse reaction
to it
just because it contained sugar which
you had not had in years
sulfites actually sorry it's very
unclear
it's all of this is very unclear still
yeah it's very
it's very interesting how ready are you
to get back to
your schedule i mean you had a question
i am i am in some sense back to my
schedule
as much as my health will allow i'm
working
from three o'clock while i do some work
before that
i spend most of the morning uh walking
and
exercising and some in correspondence
but i'm
recording two two to three podcasts on
my end a week and
i'm generally on two others during the
week and i'm writing again
so you know i'm champing at the bit uh
i have it's possible that i'll tour
again depending
on whether or not i can tolerate it that
time changes and all of that
right and then of course with kova
that's a whole well yes there's that too
well ladies and gentlemen we are talking
to dr jordan peterson
this episode we're having a great talk
with him
and um one of the things that jordan has
advocated
is um
getting getting your puss
mashed up
and
in order to [ __ ] a good puss you gotta
have blue chew
because it makes your dick hard
blue chew is a unique online service
that the lip i mean just
i've read this so many times
you know what it is you know what blue
chew is it's a unique online
service it's the same ingredients as
viagran cialis but it's in a chewable
form
and it's cheaper you take it and makes
your penis hard
and then you last longer that's what it
is
i i mean
that's what it is it's a dick pill
and you should get it
if you try it you can try it for free if
you use a promo code td at checkout
just pay 5 shipping that's bluetooth.com
promo code td
and receive your first month free and we
thank blue chew for sponsoring us it's
so important
it's chewable did you know that really
because i don't like swallowing pills
you like swallowing [ __ ]
you walked into that the process is
simple
do you know how simple it is how simple
you go to bluetooth.com
you consult with one of their licensed
medical providers
and once you're approved you'll receive
your prescription within days
the best part do you know what it is
what's that it's all done online
so you don't have to go and get you
don't have to tell a doctor you have a
soft
penis but what if you did
would it make you a better person if you
had to go to the doctor and say i cannot
get my [ __ ] hard
maybe that's something that people need
to go through
and we're depriving them of that by
doing this online
if you had to walk in the doctor and go
my
penis will not get hard
and the doctor judges you is that what
people think doctors do by the way like
they do judge you
the doctor is like what
you think that's the way a doctor would
react my doc
doc my penis doesn't get hard and he'd
go
yeah i thought so like what
like your doctor would just be like all
right take this pill
that's all it would be but it's better
to do it online
my friend um
started taking blue chew religiously
and he
[Music]
started performing much better in bed
bluetooth tablets are made in the usa
and they prepare and ship direct
go to bluetooth.com promo code td to
receive your first month free
better help help it's an online
counseling service
it's really good communicate with a
counselor in under 48 hours it's not a
crisis line not self-help
broad range of expertise available which
may not be locally available in many
areas it's available for clients
worldwide
log in your account anytime send a
message to your counselor timely and
thoughtful responses plus you can
schedule a weekly video
and or phone sessions you won't ever
have to sit in an uncomfortable waiting
room as with traditional
therapy betterhelp wants you to start
living a happier life today
it's really great you know people that
use this are happy
better help help join over a million
people have taken charge of their mental
health
with the help of an experienced
professional in fact so many people have
been using better health they're
recruiting additional counselors
counselors in all 50 states
the services available if you need it
you want it you can log in
start going tell them what you think
and they themselves will help you
if you don't really vibe with your
counselor just get another one it's not
a big deal
so many people
are taking charge of their mental health
this podcast is sponsored by better help
and tim dylan show listeners get 10
off your first month at betterhelp.com
tim d betterhelp.com tim
d and and just to ask you about that
because you are a doctor i mean i know
you're a psychologist but
when you look at sort of like a doctor
yeah it's like a you know psychologist
i've you know there's
i've said negative things about
psychologists but not
not per se the the discipline but the
person that
every my my thing is whenever i talk to
someone and i say what are you majoring
in in college and they say psychology
it's generally a person i'd never want
any advice from
and i don't that's just that's the
anecdotal evidence that's not backed up
by any data it's just
when it's just like when i say what are
you majoring in and someone says
business
i go i would never want to do business
with you it's just a
it's a very general thing that a lot of
people major in and a lot of people
i feel like don't uh come out of that in
a
smart way um but as a doctor what do you
think
about uh you know covet i mean in in
psychologically what it's done to people
the lockdowns the fear
um you know obviously the fear of
getting sick and and then
losing income what is going to be the
sum total effect in your estimation
of this entire period on the psychology
of the world and you know more
particularly this country
like you know we have a rash of
shootings now that you know we've always
had but now it seems like we're even
i mean these numbers are high even for
america um
how do we come out of this do you think
well i mean i've been struck
positively in the main by how resilient
the our social structures and
our economic structures have been in the
face of this
i mean it's we've been locked down in an
unprecedented way
for more than a year and yet
most businesses are still functioning
and
the social order has been almost
completely maintained
and with any luck we're almost out of it
i mean
in the u.s i think you guys are up to
something
like it's close to 35 percent of the
population that's been
inoculated now and that should start to
make a real difference really quick
we're a bit behind in canada partly
because we don't make our own vaccines
and so we've been dependent on supplies
from other countries
um and so i guess to some degree i'm al
so to some degree i'm surprised by
our resilience in the face of this
social and economic
um it's a remarkable thing that the
vaccines were
developed and distributed within the
span of a year
that there's so many vaccines that they
seem to be working that they're not
producing catastrophic side effects
so i think that's all extraordinarily
positive
all things considered i think the signs
of instability that are
particularly evident in the us are
attributable to
factors other than kovid
and the kovid lockdown that have been
brewing for a long time
which i've been talking about and many
other people as well for a long time
um right there are there are a rash of
shootings
that have been happening uh school
shootings and
one of my biggest disappointments
or is that all of these shootings are
done primarily by
men and it feels like it's another
thing that women have been kept out of
like you know stem
is there is there a way that's a
terrible joke
it is a terrible joke but you know it's
true
and so why are so many men
being driven to violence
well it's not so many i mean the school
shooters are a
tiny tiny infinite infinitesimal
percentage of the population
and so it's very difficult to formulate
a policy to deal with such things
because they are
in fact so rare and so unpredictable
there's i mean aggression per se is
has its uses um males are
disproportionately violent compared to
females or at least with regards to
physical violence
females have their own particular brand
of aggression
which has more to do with reputation
destruction than physical
violence and that starts very early yes
you can detect that in children
um so
and you have a very very large country
right 330 million people
the it doesn't you know one person in a
million is pretty seriously disturbed
and so that's a shooting a day if it's
one person in a million
and you don't have a shooting a day so
it's less than one in a million so
that's very very rare
and thank god for that it is it is when
you look at the numbers like that but it
does
feel uh it's too much right i mean i'm
sure that like you know when we look at
across the world at other countries that
don't have these things
is any of this attributable to the fact
that men
now and women as well too but since
we're on the topic of men
are retreating more into the digital
world uh
that they are less socialized that they
are more
into you know potential potentially uh
not to blame video games but like
people seem to be retreating from the
types of
um social structures that men had
participated in for years which was
marriage
family uh you know owning property
things like that
um and it seems like a lot of men are
not doing those things or doing those
things much later in life
and there seems to be and you've
addressed this i think as effectively as
anyone
there seems to be a tendency of those
men uh that are not
uh participating in those social
structures to
feel alienated and and uh
disenfranchised and that often leads to
you know negative pathologies how do you
encourage
the type of social commitments that
um point men in the right
direction um and i think you're a big
proponent of the
you know more traditional way of life
where it's you know
forming a bond with someone getting
married
um trying to you know uh
you know create manifest the life you
want that's a lot of the things that
you've read and you've talked about
involved that um do you see the digital
spheres being a real
problem here because people can escape
into that
i don't see the digital sphere as a as a
problem um
not as such uh i think pornography might
be a problem
that's the digital sphere well fair
enough but yeah
you'd have to decompose the digital
sphere into its various aspects and then
look at
each of them i as i said i think that
the the
ease of access of pornography and its
proliferation i think that's
not a good thing i think there are many
good things about the digital sphere
i mean there are large communities of
encouragement
that have popped up on youtube
i i suppose i am at the head of one but
there are many people doing similar
things like jocko willink is a good
example and
um and your
your question was i guess two part you
commented that
there's perhaps a disproportionate
number of people who are feeling
alienated
from the general community from life
itself from the social world from
the natural world for that matter and
that that alienated
isolated and lonely existence can lead
to bitterness and
and god only knows where that goes right
that can move in an aggressive direction
quite quickly well the antidote to that
as far as i'm concerned is
something like encouragement is partly
why i'm so appalled by the
characterization of our
society as a essentially as it
both symbolically and and literally as a
tyrannical patriarchy
you know that the criticism that emerges
on the left is essentially
that hierarchies are
predicated on power and
and power is equated to tyranny and
and then so social structure itself is
equated to tyranny and
that's nonsensical it's a nonsensical
oversimplification
the fundamental ruling principle of
a functioning hierarchy is not power
it's something more like
fatherhood it's something more like
encouragement and reciprocity
and like and and
reciprocity and courage and productivity
and generosity all of those things and
i was talking to jocko willing a couple
of weeks ago and
and he's a very assertive and
man very much capable of physical
aggression built for it and
both physically and temperamentally and
he went through the naval seal training
and
that's a prime example of a patriarchal
hierarchy let's say sure
but what they were taught most
fundamentally was that
each of them had their buddies back
right like they were taught reciprocity
right so the functional higher
part of the considerations issue with
that
uh characterization and i've listened to
a lot of your work on on hierarchies i
agree with a great deal of it
but part of it is when we see so many of
the institutions that we grew up with
the catholic church
uh the government we look at a lot of
the wars that we've been in that we now
find out
uh were foolhardy and the uh reasons we
got into them were not
initially the reasons we were told when
we look at
um uh you know mega corporations
and uh the things that they get away
with you know whether it's you know
these massive
uh fraud uh you know examples of fraud
when we look at
the the dishonesty that is inherently
seemingly baked into not only the system
but human beings
as you say it's it's not necessarily
capitalism it's deeper than that
but when you say that hierarchies are
more fatherhood or based on generosity
or cooperation
my generation is looking at so many of
the institutions that we have seen
um literally have been rotted out
from dishonest malevolent bad actors and
bad forces that seemingly
are not really checked and seem to run
amok
and are not counterbalanced by that
generosity
uh or that encouragement that you talk
about so that that seems to be when i
hear a lot of what you talk about so
much of it resonates with me
but some of it uh is hard to grasp
because it seems very
it is very positive and very hopeful
view of of hierarchies but
in light of all of the nefarious people
and their ability to poison
organizations do you not ever look at
some of those statements about
hierarchies and say that like yes
hierarchies can get poisoned
uh yes definitely yeah i mean the whole
look
a couple of observations there when
hierarchies degenerate it's because of
power and deceit
and they do degenerate and a
degenerative hierarchy
is full of lies and and and and power
games and but
i'm not characterizing hierarchies as
based on let's say productivity and
reciprocity i'm characterizing
functional hierarchies as characterized
by
productivity and reciprocity see the the
essential claim on the radical left is
that
the hierarchical structure per se is
tyrannical and predicated on power and
that's simply not true
now when the structures degenerate
that's how they degenerate and
it's definitely the case that we have to
keep our eyes open
for that occurrence that we should be
appalled by it and that
we should strive to do everything we
possibly can to stop it
but my sense of that is that starts with
you
you want to stop deceit in the world
then stop lying
if you want to stop the arbitrary
exercise of power then stop using it
now let me give you an example of this i
mean
because i'm sensitive to the criticisms
that you just laid out and the reasons
that people who young people might be
cynical about
the institutions in the institutions
that make up our culture
and there's no doubt they have the
proclivity to degenerate as i talk about
in chapter 11 that's the evil
that's the that's the tyrannical and i
just before because
you're gonna have a great answer for
this but like the other
thing is when you say it starts with you
and to a degree that's true
but it's hard for a guy like me to
believe for example when i was in
community college
the cia was running a labyrinth of
secret prisons that we all later found
out about
so it's hard for me to kind of make the
connection well if i do my homework
uh the cia's gonna stop running the
torture prison like that's the
disconnect i feel like uh with some of
the personal responsibility that it does
have a limit
where it's like i can be very honest um
how is that going to stop incredibly
powerful
people how many people are we talking to
you and me right now um 100
half a million easily okay so and you
were in community college how long ago
um good question i was there
and i went back like a real loser but i
took out i graduated high school in
2003.
so let's say this around 2004. okay so
it's 15 years roughly speaking yes
okay so you've gone from that guy 15
years ago to someone who's speaking on a
regular basis with half a million people
that is correct
so everything you say matters well you
shaped your character back when you were
in college look you have
power plenty of it and you know people
are watching you on
youtube and they're watching how you say
things and what you say and what
questions you ask and all of that and so
you have more influence than you think
well flattery will get you everywhere
you are well it's you're right about
everything when you can
when you can talk to half a million
people on a regular basis
then you have influence and god only
knows how much
and you're a comedian as well and so you
can say things that are funny and funny
things are often true
one of the characteristics of comedians
is to say true things and
that people don't expect and right
everyone cracks some of them are true
and
you know we'll see some of them are we
don't know that they're true at the time
and then months later
someone goes to jail and they are true
but um
i i've observed when when institutions
become corrupted that there's someone
heading the show
generally speaking there's individuals
who are acting in a corrupt way they're
lying
often and they're dominating
inappropriately
and the reason i picked the individual
as the focus of my attention
was because i thought that was the place
where the proclivity
for the corruption of of social
organizations could be
best addressed that's where the best
best addressed well how else could it
possibly be addressed with other
institutions
right they're going to run into the same
problem aren't they that's a fair point
so
so and uh you know you say there's
limits to personal responsibility and
i suppose that's true but it isn't
obvious to me what those limits are
i mean you climbed out from community
college to
the position of authority and influence
that you have now
and god only knows what you'll be doing
in 10 years and god only knows what you
could be doing in 10 years if you did
everything right
right and so so it isn't obvious to me
at all what the limits of personal
responsibility is and i certainly
believe that
the tr the spoken truth is absolutely
unstoppable
and so the better you are at
well i do agree with you but we do have
uh
it is a little stoppable because we are
on a website right now that can choose
to take me off
anytime they want right i mean we're
using youtube right now and they can
take me off and uh
you know we are on platforms that we
monetize our show but they can kick us
off too and then
yeah so there are you know there are
things
that uh you do run up into you know
uh you hit walls i think and i think
personal responsibility is great i think
it's important
i think it's essential for people to
live good lives
but there's a lot of seemingly
institutional
injustice out there when it comes to
the prison system in america for example
and you know uh
private prisons people making money uh
you know by by giving kids harsher
sentences
uh in the penal system you know and this
has been a you know massive scandal
there was a documentary about it called
kids for cash where you have
you know corrupt people doing horrible
things and i'm not
naive and i don't think you can ever
eradicate anything like that
but i do feel like there is
a tendency of people to say
well i'm honest and i'm doing the right
thing
but they don't hold any of those other
people to account that may be doing
horrible things to other people
so i think maybe i'm i'm definitely not
suggesting ever
that you stop with yourself right
you just start with yourself it's oh i
mean if you look at any
complex problem you could say that it
it might manifest itself at multiple
levels of social organization the
individual would be implicated but then
perhaps the your family perhaps your
community perhaps your whole country
you know you can stack up the
hierarchies the social organizations
around any given problem and then you
could say well the problem
could optimally be addressed at all of
those levels of analysis simultaneously
if you had the capacity and that's the
case i would say that
as you put your own life together and
become more responsible and more capable
and hopefully more generous and more
honest then you're going to be in much
better position to
properly assess what steps need to be
taken in the broader social realm
right i never suggested that people
limit themselves to
their room let's say but
but for me and and this makes some sense
because i am a
clinical psychologist the fundamental
unit of analysis is the individual and
i would also say that's the principle
upon which our culture is erected
that's the place that's the fundamental
place is the individual and
maybe that's because individuals feel
pain right that's where the reality is
you know
and the rest of its abstraction not that
it isn't important or relevant of course
it is
people are doing a lot of business
online now ship station allows you
to create an infrastructure that
works for your business in terms of
shipping
they allow you to worry about growing
your business in other ways while they
handle all of the shipping they import
orders from any sales channel ship with
any carrier
access discounted shipping rates
automate just about any shipping task
no matter what you're selling amazon
etsy your own website shipstation
funnels all your orders into a simple
interface
what's amazing is two months free no
hassle stress free shipping
60 days a free trial
shipstation.com click on the microphone
at the top of the page and type in tim
dillon
if you have a business it's so important
to keep costs low
so two months of a free free shipping is
great
the code is tim dillon the offer code
that's shipstation.com
enter offer code tim dillon i'm telling
you you're gonna love it
it'll definitely enable you to really
take your business to the next
level with ship station
shipstation.com enter offer code
t-i-m-d-i-l-l-o-n
tim dillon to access a two-month free
trial
and it's great small businesses can now
access the same rates that are usually
reserved for fortune 500 companies
without any of the contracts or
commitments so that's shipstation.com
promo code tim dillon you got to keep
your data private when you go online you
got to go to expressvpn hundreds of data
brokers are out there whose sole
business it is to buy and sell your data
one of these data points is your ip
address data harvesters use your ip
to uniquely identify you and your
location but with expressvpn
your connection gets recruited through
an encrypted server and my ip address is
masked
every time i turn on expressvpn i give
my random the ip address is random so
they don't know where you are what
you're doing
it's important everybody's trying to
stay sell your data it's very late
and we're trying to sell your data
not good but what you can do
is use a vpn brandon uses it right yes
because the government's always after
you
always and this whole thing now is
signal talk about signal with everyone
do you use signal should i be using
signal
whitney webb said it's good i'm sure it
is ben
but she's you know she's you know in
some hut
where people are trying to kill her
you're eating
macaroni and cheese on a picnic table
which was phenomenal today that was
really the meal of the day
much less cost that was really the meal
it always is
a barbecue in austin texas
go to expressvpn and order the barbecue
you could you could yeah of course you
can
you don't want people knowing what
you're ordering
no matter what device you're on phone
laptop or smart tv all you have to do is
tap one button you get protected
so if you're like me and you believe
that your data is your business secure
yourself with the number one data rated
vpn on the market number one
number one rated data rate you know what
i'm saying
that's it e x p r e
s s v p n dot com slash tim dillon
go to expressvpn.com tim dillon to learn
more when when you look at
you know the emerging forces in
society that are tearing it apart what
are the biggest ones
to you in your mind well
certainly ideological possession plays a
huge role and i suppose to some degree
that's probably misplaced
spirituality it's something like that
and
and so i've i've always been struck by
nietzsche and dostoevsky's analysis of
the pathology of the west you know that
we're still suffering the cataclysmic
consequences of losing our
religious grounding you need some
conceptual scheme at the highest level
of
philosophical generalization you need
some way of answering
what is good and what is evil and some
way of answering what's the purpose of
my life and
maybe what's the purpose of existence
and at that level of analysis
the only answers are religious now you
can debate the rational acceptability of
those answers but that doesn't matter
i'm talking about the the level of
analysis
problem essentially if you're talking
about such things you're in the
religious domain
well intact cultures let's say or
traditional cultures have a structure of
ritual and myth and dance and music and
art
and story that
frames that uppermost domain of
conceptualization
and people live within that when it's
fragmented and shattered as ours has
been people turn to substitutes and
and those substitutes have all too
frequently been
well either a cataclysmic loss of faith
in existence itself which is
a nihilism that has a terrible
psychological and social consequences or
the elevation of an ideological position
to the status of a religious belief
and that's not good and and so
everything in its proper place you know
you render unto caesar what is caesar's
and unto god what is god's
and you know the rationalist objector
will say well there's nothing that's
god's
and i would re respond to that
by saying be careful what you presume
right because something has to act there
something has to exist there and you
fall into a religious story so if
if with the critique you laid out for
example of social institutions you say
well they tend towards corruption
and maybe they're so corrupt that only a
fool would have faith in them
and that's a powerful argument but it's
essentially a religious argument what it
does is it
it takes the problem of evil so it
assumes that there's evil which is the
corruption and the power
maybe you don't use the term evil but it
doesn't matter it's still what you're
referring to
and then it places it in social
institutions says the problem of evil is
located
in the social institution well that's a
religious claim
it's also a faulty religious claim and
it'll twist you up and bend you around
because it's
it's incomplete and i tried to detail
that to a large degree in chapter 11
when i talked about
because you can think you can find
malevolence in your own soul you can
find malevolence in
other individuals you can find it in the
social order and you can find something
that looks like malevolence or certainly
feels like it in the natural world
right and if you only focus on one of
those then
well it's very convenient for you i mean
so one of the things i always
wonder for example if you locate evil in
the social world let's say in the
institutional world in the patriarchal
tyranny
well then you found an enemy right then
you found a target for all of your
unexamined spite and
resentment and cruelty and and homicidal
tendencies
all of that it's very dangerous
and this more sophisticated observers
and i think you can
make this case merely as a consequence
of observing literature it's more
sophisticated observers place the battle
between good and evil inside the human
soul
and and then it manifests itself in
social institutions as well but
that's not the primary locale of the
divine battle
right christopher hitchens the late
great you know
writer um had had argued
you know in a polemic god is not great
that religion should be replaced by the
canon of literature
that uh that theology should be thrown
away and replaced with literature that
all of our great lessons
uh that we need to know are in
literature do you find
fault with that well the deepest
literature is religious
okay i mean that's what hitchens didn't
realize is that
if you if you took a hundred great books
and sifted them so that you derived
one great greatest book from it
then you'd have a religious text right
and and
and it would deal with these high order
concerns that we just described and
some of that can't be done rationally
which is partly why hitchens would
locate it in literature but it's not
just literature it's also
it's also located and expressed in
architecture
you know a cathedral says something
about the structure of being now what it
says you can't exactly say
that's why there's a cathedral instead
of the description of a cathedral right
it's the same with music and and perhaps
particularly religious music but
secular music is religious music it's
just been secularized it still has the
same
it still has the same impact and the
same religions seem to be less
relevant to uh people because a lot of
not all of their not all of their uh
lessons and morals which many of them
are great
but a lot of them uh the big three let's
take which you have uh christianity
judaism in islam
um christianity went through a pretty
serious reformation
um judaism is a small religion in terms
of the
numbers of people islam is going
maybe potentially going through a
reformation now in certain countries and
other you know
politically um so when people look at
these religions and we say the answers
are to be
found there there's sort of a deep
skepticism amongst a lot of people who
look at
um you know when people were following
these religions to the letter of the law
and when they had an omnipresent uh you
know
force in the political structure of
society it was often
quite an oppressive place whether it was
you know if you look at like
the the catholic inquisition or whether
you look at you know modern day saudi
arabia for example
so there there's a skepticism about
those
belief systems being incredibly relevant
now
and then you arrive at this place where
people start believing in you know that
they're
you know an other can on tumblr or
whatever nonsense that you've
had to go up against for the last four
years so it's like
what can you create or what can
we put in that because if people for
example if you were raised a
fundamentalist christian christian man
you don't feel for whatever reason that
that belief system
suits you uh anymore
and you you are out there
and you are looking for belief and
you're looking for meaning and you're
not you're not going to find it and who
knows why that belief system doesn't
suit you i don't know it could be
your right your identity it doesn't work
it could be that your family and you
had something it could have been that
the particular church you were in was
uh abusive i know many catholics who've
left the church because of
the the litany of abuses right that has
happened
so what can we create or how do we
create
some type of and i'm not saying that we
we have to do it or it has to be a group
project i
loathe groups and i love your focus on
the individual in in that sense is what
makes you unique and interesting and the
individuals
george carlin had a great quote he goes
i love i hate people i love individuals
it was something to that degree
um but you know it i agree
wholeheartedly that the
what you see on the left right now is a
lot of people that are indoctrinating
themselves into a new religion
that is uh uh as oppressive
as unforgiving and as detrimental as a
lot of the tenets of old religion
but what can you do if you say um
you know i don't want to be a part of
that but i also don't want to be a part
of you know
sort of that you know archaic
superstitious
kind of you know belief system that you
make well that's right
that's what we're all trying to work out
isn't it is what we should do i mean
i your your comments about hitchins are
very interesting to me because
i would say in the main i've taken his
word seriously right is that i do
believe that the truth of
the the biblical truth for example is a
literary truth
it's not a scientific truth right
science isn't about morality it's about
something else whatever the bible is
about it's about morality
now you can debate the moral lessons in
the bible but the bible's an
extraordinarily complicated book so it's
not that clear
exactly what the lessons are let's say
but
having said all that i've adopted
a psychological slash literary approach
to
ethical truth and i've learned a lot
about
christianity for for example
as a consequence so and a lot of that
was from reading carl jung who wrote a
lot of what he wrote in response to
nietzsche's
observation that religion was dead that
god was dead yes yes
and so jung was influenced by freud but
at least as much by nietzsche and he was
trying to solve the problems that
nietzsche left
well you could
by definition christ is the perfect man
okay by definition right now you can
you can debate his representation in
christianity
that isn't what i mean i mean in some
sense i mean this
each of us has a relationship whether we
like it or not with the ideal
no matter how obscure and unarticulate
that
relationship is you know that because
your own
conscience will torture you and the
reason it tortures you is because you
fall short of your ideal it's
there in you now
you have a responsibility it's all it's
pretty much the nature of responsibility
to manifest yourself in accordance with
that ideal
there's no escape from that now what we
try to do collectively
is to represent that ideal and to come
to some agreement about what it is so
that we can organize ourselves
cooperatively and in productive peace
but there's no escaping from that
internal dialogue with the ideal
i mean every goal you have is a
reflection of that ideal
every aim you have every belief in
something worthwhile
all your conceptions that there is such
a thing as true
truth or your conceptions that there are
good ways of acting and evil ways of
acting
all of that presupposes an implicit
ideal part of what religious
what our religious structures have done
was focus on christianity is to try to
make that implicit ideal explicit
to represent it so that we can
understand it more and more deeply and
and so that we can also live
out its dictates let's say more
consciously
and we are we're always doing this
whether we know it or not so for example
you and i to the degree that we're able
to have this conversation
in a manner that is genuinely reflective
of
us a seeking of the truth
then we're manifesting a religious ideal
in the
context of the conversation and that's
why we're interested in it and that's
why other people are watching it
right and they don't have to know that
and they'll say that was meaningful
that struck me i i learned something uh
you know i thought i'd watch for five
minutes but i watched for an hour
right we can't help it this grips us so
for
for example you'll find yourself
respecting or disrespecting
people spontaneously you'll find
yourself in awe
of someone or not or contemptuous of
them
all of that means that you're in the
grip of a moral evaluation that's
related to this implicit ideal
and you know the more i've looked at the
representation of that implicit ideal in
religious
uh texts let's say but in the broader
religious culture the more i'm struck by
its profundity
so for for example i use this story
quite
frequently but the story of cain and
abel in in
genesis is very very short it's only
half a paragraph long it's very very
short
but it lays out very clearly the
dichotomy
of personality that exists inside the
human soul
there's part of us that part that's
represented by abel that
is striving towards the light that's
attempting to serve our own interests
and the interests of the broader
community and perhaps the divine
interest to the best of our
ability believing it
intrinsically in the in the basic
goodness of
existence and there's another part of us
that's rendered
cynical and bitter and murderous by
the tragedy of life and our sequential
catastrophic failures and inability to
put ourselves together
and cruelty of the world and that's
humanity where all of us are caught
between the
in the battle between those two opposing
viewpoints
it's religious to the core and we
when we lose christianity let's say we
lose thousands of years of the attempt
to make that
implicit reality explicit and
that's a catastrophe now we replace it
quite quickly we replace it with the
avengers universe
you know where we watch the battle
between good and evil being played out
in movies that cost hundreds of millions
of dollars to make and that push our
computational resources to the limit
think about that you know the most
sophisticated computational devices
on earth are used to generate artificial
realities where we can explore the
battle between good and evil
and then we line up and pay you know
inordinate amounts of money to expose
ourselves to this
and we find it gripping now we write it
off as entertainment
i don't write it off as entertainment i
take it seriously
right it's a serious business i think
the real conflict comes into
um you know what the ideal is
and of course that's the real
that's where the real meat of the
problem
lies right and and that to to agree on
that
and to agree on the steps to perfecting
yourself into that
is where you're going to find a lot of
the discord which i know you know
of course i know that you know you've
waded into those waters and they're um
i i love everything you say about groups
i loathe groups i don't know
why i do it is something that i
uh i was born uh with a natural aversion
to
group think and i'm i'm not not that i
can't be caught up in it like every
other human being can and i'm sure
people i can see the youtube comments
already thinking
you know but i just don't i don't
you know i'm a gay person for example
but i find the gay movement completely
insane
i don't think they represent me i think
a lot of the things that they want
are absurd and i've been vocal about
uh you know giving hormones to children
that are
that are you know questioning their
gender identity i think is ludicrous i
think it's abusive
i've said that um i've said that the
moralizing
and the making people like you and the
making them love you and the idea that
they need
to conform to your belief system to me
is i've had no interest in that i have
no interest in spending my time on this
planet
getting people to think i'm a worthwhile
human being
uh and maybe that's because i'm i'm an
addict so as an addict i can't
entertain uh other people's ideas of me
too much because then they become
resentments and those resentments lead
me back to addiction
so i have to just do what i do and i've
attracted an audience based on the fact
that they know that i don't
care that much because i can't care it's
not that i'm morally superior
if i'm to stay sober and to stay
effective um
i can't entertain people's ideas about
me too much i can
i can make sure that i'm why is that
linked why is that linked to your
ability to stay away from addictive
substances because
do you know the resentments that i will
build up you know there's a great line
and
oh i see yeah the resentments you know
if you okay so think about that so so if
you deviate from your
inbuilt sense of ethics right then the
consequences of that will be so
catastrophic that you have to drug
yourself into
correct and to insensate uh existence
correct right well that's exactly what i
mean about the depth of the moral
impulse
right you violated at your peril yes
and you know you you talk about
agreement like there are things we
pretty broadly agree on sure i would say
i'm sure well
no one no one virtually no one thinks
it's a good idea to teach your child to
lie
right so we we have a pretty deep
respect for the truth now right
we may quibble about when it's okay to
bend it right
but generally speaking we all respect
and admire honesty
and presume it and and attempt to to
live
in a relatively honest manner now i know
there are
exceptions there are excellent some
various exceptions to everything
well you know my experience has been
that you don't think that like in the
world yes our society is set up
we're kind of it's we're we tolerate a
certain level of dishonesty everything
from the television shows we watch to
our political uh
system we kind of expect on some level
that the people
that are in front of us are not
necessarily
this is why i think you by the way have
taken off so dramatically because the
things you were saying you believe
i can tell that and the people that are
watching this can tell that whether they
agree with you or not
i think when you watch how staged and
manufactured
american culture is media culture
entertainment culture political culture
we've all become a little cynical
and we all expect a healthy dose of
deceit
with most culture that we get and that's
why i think people like yourself have
broken through that
academic culture i believe as you said
many people are afraid to say publicly
what they need to say or what they have
said privately and i experienced this
in my business too so while i think the
idealist honesty would be great i do
believe we've been conditioned to expect
far less honesty
than we should have well look
there's a couple of i have a couple of
thoughts about that the first is
what we should tolerate on average
about as much deception from other
people as we tolerate on average from
ourselves
because there's no reason to
assume that there's no reason to assume
anything other than that right and and
we have to
allow our institutions to move forward
despite the fact that they're composed
of people who
on average are as corrupt and deceitful
as we are
right so so some of that's not so much
cynicism as wisdom
okay and i would say that's built in
that's a particularly notable feature of
the american political system because
it's been made explicit by the founders
of your
of your state they aim to produce a
system that people who were about as
deceitful and unadmirable as they were
wouldn't screw up too badly that was
their goal
and that was very wise right now having
said that
i do believe nonetheless that we
should strive for better and that we
actually want it
and one of the things i have seen that's
very heartening is that
now that the broad now that the
bandwidth limitation has been
blown off video and audio communication
and the cost has been brought down to
zero essentially
people are starving for genuine
conversation that's true
as you know yes you're you're you're
making your living yes
doing that 100 and and and you
i mean tell me if i'm wrong about this
but my experience with
youtube audiences and with my public
lecture audiences is
but more specifically youtube is that
it's a this long-form discussion medium
brutally punishes dishonesty yes and
insincerity yes
if people spend that amount of time with
you
they have to know who you are or they
have to want to spend time with you
or you have to have a demonstrable skill
set that they find valuable
yes and the conversation has to take
place in a certain way right now
i'm increasingly struck by the
disjunction between a standard media
interview
and this kind of discussion right i mean
we didn't structure this
none nothing you're not attempting to
do something with me other than have an
interesting conversation right
hopefully you're asking me questions
that are actually your questions
now if i go to a standard interview
yeah especially if it's a television
interview then
i'll be confronted with someone who's
the face of the
bureaucracy and virtually none of the
questions they ask
have anything to do with what they're
interested in so it's
right there's an artificiality about it
that's that can easily translate into
manipulation not only i might not ask
you other people's questions i didn't i
barely prepared
i was just i've seen enough of you that
i said
it makes more sense for me to have a
genuine conversation
than to prepare uh questions
i i said i'm just going to kind of go
with the flow which is i
yeah i don't people often offer to send
me
questions before a discussion like this
and i always refuse right
and it's for that reason is and i think
part of the reason that people
enjoy this form of communication is
because it has the same quality as
free-form jazz right or or or
i mean the same thing happens in other
genres of music when the when the band
members are
jamming it's spontaneous creation yes
and and to the degree that we're capable
of
engaging in that then we keep our
audience
along that we take our audience along
for the ride
yes and so and so this also relates back
to your
first question about the online world i
mean
i think it's an unbelievably powerful
and useful
method of communication it's obviously
decimating the legacy media
and for good reason it's technologically
superior and ethically superior
in every way so that's very heartening
you can have real discussions i mean my
life right now consists of pretty much
nothing but a series of genuine
discussions and
are there as genuine as i can make them
and i'm always trying to learn something
from whatever discussion i have i don't
go in there with a goal
in mind except to to have an honest
think as deeply
seek as deeply as i can into the
conversation yeah and and we we
we appreciate doing this you have two
more questions for you this book by the
way
beyond order uh 12 more rules for life
is available everywhere
right now you should grab it and read it
and then hopefully you'll be back on a
speaking tour
uh relatively soon and hopefully i
you've sat down with stupider
interviewers than me i think you have
now i've watched some of your interviews
i think you have um
things that you would recommend that
people read
if people want to out there want to be
smarter or they want to
understand you better outside of your
own books which are
obviously uh 12 rules for life and 12
more rules for life and then other
things you've written as well
uh i always with somebody like you i
always like you to
recommend reading because you know when
you're talking about nietzsche and jung
and everything
a lot of people are not connected with
that stuff in a meaningful way
so is there a way are there things you
recommend for them to
read on my website jordanbpeterson.com
under books
i have a list of about 100 recommended
books and
people are buying those a lot of those
books i keep track of their sales and
if you find the ideas that i'm
presenting
interesting you'll find the books in
that list
interesting they'll be temperamentally
suitable for you but
it you'd get a decent you'd get the
equivalent of a good humanities
education if you read all those books
better i would say and so that's
and they're great books dostoyevsky for
example if if you are a fiction reader
and you like exciting fiction
dostoyevsky was a master at
plotting a thriller his books are
unbelievably engrossing and they're
incredibly deep he's very good have you
read chelsea handler
handler no i haven't well she's we'll
we'll she will
i'll send you something of her she'll
check she's pretty good um
jordanbpederson.com when you are doing a
speaking tour
all of your uh dates will be up there
you can you can purchase the book there
as well uh
thank you for coming on i know your
schedule is busy and you
but you are making time for a lot of
people and you've done a lot of my
friends podcasts and
um obviously we we really appreciate it
jordan and
i mean i don't know that we've solved
the world's problems but we've
we've solved the problem of people that
wanted to kill an hour in a
smart and enlightening way well that's
something to solve that is an hour isn't
it
that is something to solve all right
thank you very much we really appreciate
it
yeah well thanks very much for the
invitation all right thank you so much
michaela i said hello and
i'm gonna cut out sugar soon all right
all right thank you thanks so much all
right bye bye